Oh, listener, welcome to our show. It's called Smartless and it's going to be incredible. Oh, settle in. The stuff we've got for you today. Oh, man, cinch your speedo because we're really going to get going on this one. Yeah. Oh, man. Welcome to Smartless.
噢，听众朋友们，欢迎收听我们的节目。它叫 Smartless，而且一定会非常精彩。噢，安顿下来吧。我们今天为您准备的这些东西。噢，天哪，系好你的泳衣，因为我们这次真的要火力全开了。耶。噢，天哪。欢迎来到 Smartless。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Hi, everybody. Oh, so I am in a remote location. Will is in a remote location.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。大家好。噢，所以我现在在一个异地。威尔在一个异地。
Sean. Still at home. You look like you're in a different room in the castle. No, I just have the door open because the dog is laying down behind me. He's been kind of slow today. Gassy. Oh, geez. Walk us through it.
肖恩。还在家里。你看上去好像在城堡的另一个房间里。不，我只是把门开着，因为狗正趴在我身后。他今天有点没精神。放屁。噢，天哪。带我们了解一下。
I mean, this, what a story. Well, why are you leaving the door open for the, for a slow dog? Because he can't see him. He's on the floor. Because it takes him a while to get through because he's slow. I don't know. I just want him to let him know he's not alone. Huh.
我是说，这个，这算什么故事。嗯，你为什么要给那只，给那只没精神的狗开着门？因为他看不见他。他在地板上。因为他穿过门需要花点时间，因为他没精神。我不知道。我只是想让他知道他并不孤单。哈。
Bless your heart. What do you do for Scotty? You also leave a door open for Scotty? No. But you know what? If you pan your camera down and Scotty was laying next to the dog on the floor. No, but you know, we got in a little tiff today because he, he rightfully so, he is correct.
祝你心想事成。你对斯科蒂怎么做？你也给斯科蒂留着门吗？不。但你知道吗？如果你把镜头往下移，斯科蒂就趴在地板上的狗旁边。不，但你知道，我们今天有点小摩擦，因为他，理所当然地，他是对的。
We, I interrupt him too much is what we argued about. Sure. Do you guys really get that a lot? No, because like I, I know what he's going to say. So I'm just like, and I finished the sentence and he's like, can you just let me finish what my thought was? Can I tell you something? Yeah.
我们，我打断他太多次了，这就是我们争论的焦点。当然。你们真的经常遇到这种情况吗？不，因为就像，我知道他要说什么。所以我就会，然后我接话，他就说，你能不能让我把话说完？我能告诉你一件事吗？耶。
I got to say I'm with Scotty on this. This has been a pet peeve of mine for a while. I have certain people who are close to me. I'm not going to name them, but I grew up with them and we're related. And they go, and they go, you go like, oh man. So the other day I was coming down the street, no, I was, I was coming down the canyon and I was noticing that it was sunny and you're like, Oh, do you just want to guess what I'm going to say?
我不得不说我在这件事上支持斯科蒂。这很长一段时间以来一直是我的一个痛点。我有几个亲近的人。我不打算点名，但我跟他们一起长大，我们有亲戚关系。他们就会说，然后他们会说，你会说，噢，天哪。所以那天我正顺着街道走，不，我当时正在，我正顺着峡谷走，我注意到天气很好，然后你就会说，噢，你只是想猜我要说什么？
Or do you want me to say it? I know it's a thing. Trust me. Fucking mental. It makes you feel like people just want you to get on with it, right? My wife does the same thing to me and I'm like, Oh, I'm sorry if I'm boring you. That's exactly what Scotty said. Jason, I get it with you.
还是你想让我说出来？我知道这是个毛病。相信我。简直有病。这会让你觉得别人只是想让你快点说完，对吧？我妻子对我做同样的事，然后我就像，噢，如果我让你觉得无聊了，我很抱歉。斯科蒂就是这么说的。杰森，我从你身上能体会到。
It is that you're boring her. And I get it. She's not wrong because you're a little bit slow and too deliberate sometimes with me. It's not that. You see, I'm able to see it. I know. I know. I was listening to what the Tony Hawk episode today and I'm like, Jesus, Jason, I, you
就是你让她感到无聊。我能理解。她说得没错，因为你有时对我来说有点慢吞吞、太墨迹了。不是那样的。你看，我能看出来。我知道。我知道。我今天在听托尼·霍克那一集，我想，天哪，杰森，我，你
know, I talked to myself in third person when I'm in the car, get on with the question. Like the listener and the questioner, questioner, questionnaire, subject, interviewee. They get it. Oh, God. It's just fun. Just go ahead and just chop it off and let them talk. Yeah. No, but sometimes you have to relate before you ask the question.
知道，我在车里时用第三人称自言自语，快切入正题吧。就像听众和提问者，提问者，调查问卷，对象，被采访者。他们懂的。噢，天哪。这纯粹是好玩。干脆直接切断，让他们畅所欲言好了。耶。不，但有时你在提问前必须先建立联系。
You did have a long question. You did have a really long question from Tony Hawk that was fucking crazy. I always do though. Maybe I'd just like to hear. I kind of don't mind it because you have to give the question context. So sometimes it takes a second, right? But that's just it. You don't have to.
你确实问了一个很长的问题。你确实问了托尼·霍克一个非常长的问题，简直疯狂。我总是这样。也许我只是想听听。我倒觉得无所谓，因为你必须给问题提供背景。所以有时需要花上一秒钟，对吧？但关键就在于。你根本不用。
When you're listening to it, you're like, I get it or I'm ahead of you. Shut up. Well, my questions are like, what's your favorite color and stuff like that. So I guess they just kind of, yeah, no, your questions, you're, it's a whole different thing with you. And you know, after the session, we're going to have a real sit down, okay. Broadway. Just stay on your zoom.
当你听的时候，你会想，我懂了，或者我比你走在前面。闭嘴吧。好吧，我的问题就像是，你最喜欢什么颜色之类的。所以我想他们只是，耶，不，你的问题，你，你完全是另外一回事。你知道，在这期节目结束后，我们要好好坐下来谈谈，好吗。百老汇。就呆在你的 zoom 上。
By the way, the Tony Hawk episode, I listened to it as well the other day and we, I got burned on the Broadway question when I said I made fun and then he was like, I am doing a Broadway show. I know. How about that? That's true. See? God, we're all so dumb.
顺便说一句，托尼·霍克那一集，我前几天也听了，当我说笑然后他却说我正在出演一幕百老汇演出时，我在百老汇的问题上狠狠栽了个跟头。我知道。怎么样？真的。看吧？天哪，我们都太蠢了。
I haven't finished the episode yet. How does it end? We all died. Yeah, we all died. We all did it. We did it. And the butler did it. Oh, but here's the good news.
我还没听完那一集呢。结局是怎样的？我们都死了。耶，我们都死了。我们都做了。我们做到了。管家干的。噢，但好消息是。
We have a butler. Hey, listen, I want to get to our guests because our guest is a very busy person. I'm so, to say I'm thrilled is like the understatement of the century. I'm so excited to have this guy on our program. He is a prime minister of Canada, an incredible artist, an incredible activist who this isn't one of these things where like activists for 10 minutes and then like, God, everybody noticed. And so like I'm back to doing what I do.
我们有个管家。嘿，听着，我想请出我们的嘉宾，因为我们的嘉宾是个大忙人。我，说我激动得简直是世纪之 understatement（保守说法）。我太高兴能请这家伙来我们的节目了。他是加拿大的前总理，一位杰出的艺术家，一位杰出的活动家，而这并非那种“当了 10 分钟活动家然后觉得，天哪，每个人都注意到我了，所以我回去做我该做的事”的人。
This is a person who's not just talking to talk, but walking the walk and it's really fucking admirable and incredible, especially in a time that's so complicated and so many issues are pressing in so many real fucking ways. This is a boots on the ground activist. This is a fucking artist who shares with you, Jason, something that they, that not a lot of people know that you both basically got your start on Little House on the Prairie. Is this Andy Dick? No, this person is a five time Academy Award nominee and two time Academy Award winner
这是一个不仅空谈，而且付诸行动的人，这真的非常该死的令人钦佩和不可思议，尤其在这个如此复杂、有这么多真实问题亟待解决的时代。这是一个脚踏实地的活动家。这是一个他妈的艺术家，他与你分享，杰森，许多人并不知道的一点，即你们俩基本上都是从《草原小屋》开始起步的。这是安迪·迪克吗？不，这个人曾五次获得奥斯卡金曲奖提名，并两次获得奥斯卡金曲奖
for best actor. I just got to get right to it. This is Sean Penn. Oh my God. There he is. Sean Penn. Hi, fellas. You started on Little House and the Prairie?
最佳男主角。我得开门见山了。这是肖恩·潘。噢，天哪。他来了。肖恩·潘。嗨，伙计们。你们是从《草原小屋》开始的？
Come on. It's a summer job as an extra. Yeah. Incredible. Oh wow. That's so cool. Were you sitting on a folding chair and holding the whole time? It's funny you ask that because the principal memory I have was when they broke for lunch.
拜托。那是一份兼职做群演的工作。耶。太不可思议了。噢，哇。太酷了。你当时是坐在折叠椅上撑了全场吗？你这么问真逗，我主要的记忆是他们休息吃午饭的时候。
They said, we just need to get first team through. Well, I didn't feel it was proper to go to an organized lunch that wasn't within the time period. So I stayed out in the sun and see the Valley and as soon as they got back and we're ready to shoot, I fell down from sun exhaustion. Oh, I thought you were going to say that you went in and you churned your own butter. Sean, I just said this today. I was sitting on the couch with my husband, Scottie.
他们说，我们只需要让第一梯队过去。嗯，我觉得去吃一个不在规定时间内组织的午餐不太合适。所以我留在阳光下，看着山谷，他们一回来准备拍摄，我就因为中暑虚脱倒下了。噢，我还以为你要说你进去自己打奶油了呢。肖恩，我今天刚说过这个。我正和我的丈夫斯科蒂坐在沙发上。
Your trailer was playing for your new movie called Flag Day. Flag Day. Flag Day. Flag Day. And I said, one of the greatest scripts I've ever read in my life. I said, that movie looks amazing. There's nothing this guy can't do. It already looks incredible.
你的新电影《国旗日》的预告片正在播放。国旗日。国旗日。国旗日。我说，这是我这辈子读过的最伟大的剧本之一。我说，那部电影看起来太棒了。这家伙没有什么是做不到的。看起来就已经不可思议了。
Your performance just from the trailer is incredible. So it's so bizarre that you're sitting here right now. It was just an hour ago. It's like, that guy's amazing. I was going to get to Flag Day later, but Sean, get right into Flag Day. Let's talk about it, man. I mean, this. No, I'm serious.
仅仅从预告片来看，你的表演就不可思议。所以你现在就坐在这里真是太离奇了。就在一个小时前。就像，那家伙太棒了。我本来打算晚点聊《国旗日》，但肖恩，我们直接切入《国旗日》吧。我们来聊聊，老兄。我是说，这个。不，我是认真的。
I just did. I just did. It looks incredible. I know nothing about that story. I know nothing about any. I just literally just an hour ago said, that movie looks amazing. I will see that. That's great to hear.
我刚刚说过了。我刚刚说了。看起来不可思议。我对那个故事一无所知。我对任何事都一无所知。我真的就在一个小时前说过，那部电影看起来太棒了。我要去看。听到这个真高兴。
Yeah. It was a script that came to me many years ago based on Jennifer Vogel's memoir, Flim Flam Man, it's a father daughter story in which, which is led really by the daughter who plays Jennifer Vogel and played by my daughter, Dylan Penn, who really had done, you know, little parts and things here and there over the years. I was, she was reluctant to try to pull this one off and then just stepped into it as a truth machine and, and gave us something magic. So it's a movie I've got several reasons to be excited about.
耶。这是多年前找上我的一个剧本，改编自詹妮弗·沃格尔的回忆录《骗子》，这是一个关于父亲和女儿的故事，其中真正的主导是扮演詹妮弗·沃格尔的女儿，由我的女儿迪伦·潘饰演，她这些年来其实零零星星演过一些小角色。我，她起初很不情愿尝试完成这部作品，然后就像一台真相机器一样投入其中，为我们带来了某种神奇的东西。所以这是一部让我有好几个理由感到兴奋的电影。
My son is also in it, Hopper Jack. That's cool. So yeah. Did you try a long time to get them to work with them? Was it, did it take a lot of convincing? It was, in particular with my daughter, she, she was of the school thought as a teenager that the, the work that her parents did was absolutely silly dressing up, adults dressing up and playing other people.
我儿子也在里面，霍珀·杰克。太酷了。所以，是的。你花了很长时间说服他们来合作吗？这需要很多游说吗？特别是对我的女儿，她曾处于那种认为父母的工作完全是愚蠢的成年人盛装打扮并扮演其他人的青少年思想学派。
And it took her time to acquire a, a respect for the work and, and for the people who do it, um, in that sense and, and, and so she, yet she had always been interested in being behind the camera to, to be in the film industry. And so I would go to Dylan every couple of years, um, when this script would appear, when Flag Day would appear because by appear, I mean the journey it goes on when you, you can't get the actress you want and in this case, her face was imprinted on that role to me. Um, and, and so you have to tell those producers, you guys should go on your way and find somebody
她花了一些时间才对这项工作以及从事这项工作的人建立起一种尊重，从那种意义上说，所以，然而她一直对幕后工作很感兴趣，想要进入电影行业。所以每隔几年当这个剧本出现时，当《国旗日》出现时，我都会去找迪伦，因为所谓的出现，是指当你经历一段旅程，当你找不到你想要的演员时——在这个例子中，在我看来她的脸已经深深印在这个角色上了。所以你必须告诉那些制片人，你们应该另请高明去完成这件事。
else to do this. And then it, it fortunately came back around at a, at a point where she had, she felt she had lived enough life to invest in, in, in, in understanding it, um, and, and had spent enough time on sets to kind of get her sea legs in that sense. And then she just came out and rocked it. So it was, yeah, it was a long, it was a long time because she was very reluctant about it. Yeah.
然后，幸运的是，它在某个时间点又回到了她身边，那时她觉得她已经经历足够的生活来投资并理解它，并且在片场花足够的时间来找到她的方向感。然后她一上场就惊艳全场。所以，是的，这是一个漫长的过程，这是一个漫长的过程，因为她对此非常抗拒。耶。
That's how does she gain the respect for what, what you and Robin do? Did it take her, uh, just trying it and going, Oh wow, uh, this is, this feels different than what I thought. I think it was more or less that there's an irreverence that the children have for parents who aren't doctors. So you, which I understand, of course, uh, and, and so it, it's sort of an exaggerated reaction for a time, but then as she started to be, you know, moved by the work that people do on both sides of the camera and movies and, and, and, um, provoked by it and, and
她是怎样对你和罗宾所做的事情产生敬意的？这花了她，呃，只是去尝试然后说，噢，哇，呃，这感觉和我原以为的不一样吗？我想或多或少是因为孩子们对不是医生的父母有一种不敬。所以，我当然理解这一点，呃，所以，有一段时间这是一种夸张的反应，但后来随着她开始被，你知道，电影中摄像机两边的人们所做的工作所感动，并且，呃，被它所激发，并且
where she was being hit by it as she perhaps at a young age was being hit by paintings or music, uh, then it just developed into a more mature sense of it and a, and a more mature embrace of it. What was your relationship to, like, did you identify with that? Because of course you grew up and your dad was a filmmaker. What was that like for you to have, to have your own kid who had a different relationship to the arts and like you got into it so young and then she kind of went a different path. Well, I, I mean the, the age I really got into it was, uh, when I graduated high school
在年轻时或许曾被绘画或音乐所触动的地方，她被它所触动，然后这演变成一种更成熟的感觉和更成熟的拥抱。你对——比如，你认同这一点吗？因为你当然是在成长过程中，你父亲是一位电影制作人。当你有这样一个对艺术有不同关系的孩子，而你又这么年轻就进入这个行业，然后她却走了另一条路，你对此有什么感受？好吧，我的意思是，我真正进入这个行业的年龄是，呃，我在 17 岁快结束时高中毕业，但是我们，你知道，当我们提到《草原小屋》时，那实际上只是为了作为群演往口袋里放几个硬币。没错。
late in my 17th year, uh, but we, you know, when I, when we mentioned little house on the prairie, that was virtually just to, to put a couple of pennies in my pocket as a, as an extra. Right. I didn't have any sense that though my parents were involved in theater and, and film, I had no sense that that's the direction that I'd be going. I was spending my time in high school reading the books of F. Lee Bailey about his cases and wanting to be a, a lawyer, a criminal defense attorney.
我没有任何感觉——尽管我的父母都参与了戏剧和电影，但我没有觉得那是我要走的方向。我高中时的时间都花在阅读 F·李·贝利关于他的案件的书籍上，并想成为一名律师，一名刑事辩护律师。
Wow. Then in a senior year, I started getting involved with my younger brother and a group of friends who had gotten a hold of a super eight camera with the magnetic sound strip on it so that you could actually make, uh, talkies. And so we started making those and because we were shooting an awful lot at night, uh, when other kids were doing homework and you couldn't get them to come out and be your actors, I would be directing those movies and acting in them at a certain point. I was, I felt so invested in, in film, but there was, I didn't know what the outlet would
哇。然后在高三时，我开始和我弟弟以及一群朋友接触，他们搞到了一台带磁性音轨的超 8 毫米摄像机，这样你实际上就可以制作“有声电影”了。所以我们开始制作这些电影，因为我们在晚上拍摄得非常多——当其他孩子在做家庭作业而你无法叫他们出来当演员时——我就会在某个时候导演这些电影并在其中表演。我觉得自己对电影投入了极大的热情，但我不知道出口会在哪里。
be. And I knew that to direct, you need somebody to entrust millions of dollars on your back. So I went into a repertory company as an actor and very quickly became impassioned about that and, and then working in class and so on. And the next thing I knew, I was, uh, working in the theater regularly and then from that into film and then after, after about 10 years of that, 11 years of that, I finally got to do what I'd started out with the intention to do at stage 17, which was to direct my first film.
而且我知道要当导演，你需要有人把数百万美元托付在你的背上。所以我作为一名演员加入了一家剧目剧团，并很快对表演产生了热情，然后去上表演课等等。接下来我知道的是，我，呃，开始定期在剧院工作，然后从那里进入电影界，在大约 10 年、11 年的经历之后，我终于做了我从 17 岁时就立志要做的事，那就是导演我的第一部电影。
That's so cool. You know, I just watched the, I just watched the Val Kilmer documentary. I don't know if you've seen that. Yes, I have seen it. Yeah. It's really, really great. And, uh, he just seems like such a great guy, such a trooper, but, um, but there's footage of you backstage in New York and some, you're also young and it was this mind blowing, you
太酷了。你知道，我刚看，我刚看了方·基默的纪录片。我不知道你有没有看过。是的，我看过。耶。真的非常棒。而且，呃，他看起来真的是个很棒的家伙，一个真正的硬汉，但是，呃，里面有你在纽约后台的一些镜头，你们当时都很年轻，那真是让人大开眼界，
know, cause a lot of people think, Oh, you just come out of the womb and all of a sudden you're a movie star, but you know, people have no context about what it takes to achieve what you've achieved. And to see that footage of you, just as a kid, just, uh, and I don't know what the play was, but it was so cool to see that, that A, that he had that footage and then B, to see that you all were just hanging out like regular people backstage or super cool. Yeah. I remembered that Val, uh, had, you know, this, uh, video camera, which was, I think,
你知道，因为很多人觉得，噢，你一出生突然就成了电影明星，但你知道，人们对于取得你所取得的成就需要付出什么毫无概念。看到你作为孩子的那些镜头，只是一一我不知道那是哪部戏，但看到那种，A，他有那些镜头，然后 B，看到你们所有人就像普通人一样在后台闲逛，真是酷毙了。耶。我记得方，呃，有，你知道，这个，呃，摄像机，这在当时我想是个相当新鲜的事物。耶。耶。你当时就像是，那是摄像机吗？哇。你对此惊叹不已。耶。而他也是。
a fairly novel thing at that, at that time. Yeah. Yeah. You were like, is that a video camera? Wow. You were blown away by that. Yeah. And he was.
抱歉。威斯康星州的特蕾西，一台摄像机。老兄，他们在威斯康星州知道那是什么吗？不，也许吧。我不知道。你指出来很好。对我来说这挺科幻的，呃，而且他一直都这样。天哪，是的。
Sorry. Tracy in Wisconsin, a video camera. Do they know what that is in Wisconsin, dude? No, maybe. I don't know. It's good that you pointed it. It was pretty sci-fi to me and, uh, and he was consistent with it. And boy, yes.
我，正如肖恩所说，我是说，随着时间的推移，他成长为一个多么极其富有创造力、充满魔力的家伙。而且，呃，是的，这真的是一部人们应该看的电影。太轰动了。耶。真的太酷了。你知道，有些有趣的，呃，肖恩，那是你开始的，呃，呃，不是你，海兹。当然。
I, as Sean said, I mean, what an extraordinarily creative, uh, kind of magical guy he developed into over time. And, uh, yeah, it's, it's really a film people should see. It's sensational. Yeah. Really cool. You know, it's some funny, uh, Sean, is that you started, uh, uh, not, not you haze. Sure.
我接下来的节目都要叫你海兹了，肖恩。当然。没问题。这说得通。耶。你要向肖恩·潘妥协，不过我们，你知道，你，你做了所有这些事，你作为演员工作，你做了所有那些事，你真的就像你说的，试图去做你一直立志要做的事，那就是
I'm going to call, I'm going to call you haze for the rest of the show, Sean. Sure. That's fine. That makes sense. Yeah. You're going to defer to Sean Penn, but we, you know, you, you did all this stuff and you worked as an actor and you did all that stuff and you really kind of, as you said, kind of trying to get to the thing that you would always set out to do, which was to
成为一名导演，因为你想去做那件事。然而在那段时间里，你也创造并留下了如此多令人难忘的表演，从很多方面来说，这些表演只是。我不是在替你说话，但，但它们就像是在做你想做的事情的必经之路。我最近看到你在谈论《开放的美国学府》，而且，呃，我很抱歉，因为我确信你可能已经累了，或者你可能对谈论它不累，但你知道吗？我不在乎。
be a director because you wanted to, to do that. And yet in that time you also created and had so many memorable performances, which were just kind of in a lot of ways. I'm not putting words in your mouth, but, but like they were kind of on the road to doing what you wanted to do. And I saw you talking about fast times recently and, and I'm sorry because I'm sure you're, maybe you're tired or maybe you're not tired of talking about it, but you know what? I don't care.
让我们，耶。我也不在乎。我们在这里，我们得谈谈它。我是说，你，你实际上创造了一种全新的角色类型。这就好比在棒球比赛中发明了打点（RBI）。你知道，这就好像他们很长一段时间没有这项统计数据一样。每个人都有一个坏蛋之类的，而你发明了瘾君子，直到今天，这在配角——好吧，现在
Let's, yeah. I don't care either. We're here and we got to talk about it. I mean, you, you actually created a whole genre of, of character. It's like, it's like inventing the RBI in baseball. You know, it's like they don't have a stat for a long time. Everybody had a bad guy and blah, blah, and you invented the stoner, which to this day is a, is a whole fucking genre from a performance in a, you know, in a supporting, well, now
我要说的是主角，因为你真的撑起了那部电影。我记得我第一次看的时候。我记得那种感觉，我记得我笑得前所未有，心想，操，真是个，然后直到我年纪大了一点才觉得，等等，我直到现在才意识到那是多么天才。操我，老兄。就像那部电影，那部电影上映时你在哪里？因为你知道，这显然是一部伟大的电影，而且这是一部非常好的电影。
I'd say a starring role because you really took that movie. And I remember the first time I saw it. I remember the feeling that, I remember laughing in a way that I hadn't laughed before and thinking like, fuck, what a, and then it wasn't till I was older and going like, wait, I didn't even recognize how genius that was until now. Like, fuck me, man. Like that movie, where were you at when that movie came? Cause it's, you know, it was obviously a great movie and it's a really good film.
当你读到那个剧本并心想，好吧，杰夫·斯皮科利，我要这么做时，你生命中的那个点你在哪里？你在哪里，你从哪里来？这些人是你认识的，还是这些，你知道，你知道，有趣的是，关于领养有这么个事，你知道，我曾经和马尔科姆·格拉德威尔有过一次谈话，他告诉我，你知道，电脑鼠标存在了 20 年才有人开始使用它。我认为那部电影发生的事情之一——我待会儿会绕回到我当时的处境——我认为那个角色的本质在当时弥漫在空气中，我们当时还没有认出它，但它确实弥漫在空气中，这就是为什么一旦它被搬上 40 英尺的银幕，它就有点像，我认为像野火一样蔓延开来。你当时说，我认识那家伙。我甚至不知道有两个。没错。没错。就像我真的认识那家伙。
Where were you at at that point in your life when you read that and you were like, all right, Jeff Spicoli, I'm going to do this, like where, where were you, where were you coming from? And were these people that you knew, were these, you know, You know, it's funny, there's this thing about adoption, you know, I was, I one time had a conversation with Malcolm Gladwell and he told me that, you know, it took the computer mouse existed for 20 years before anybody started using it. And I think that one of the things that happened with that movie, and I'll circle back to
没错。事实上，在我当时的生活中，我，你知道，你得去问卡梅伦·克罗这是否属实，我确信我问过，但我记不清了。我读他的书时的感觉——我在剧本出来之前就读过这本书，很多人不知道那在成为剧本之前是一本书——我读到那个角色时，觉得那就是他在节奏等方面所写的东西。
where I was at, I think that the nature of that character was in the ether, that we weren't identifying it yet, but that it was, it was in the ether, which is why it kind of caught, I think caught like wildfire once it was on a 40 foot screen. You said, I know that guy. I didn't know there were two of them. Right. Right. Like I literally, I know that dude.
我邻居里确实有这么一个人，可以说是它的绝佳原型。事实上，大约一年前，我从海滩小道上走上来，一个看起来非常正派的绅士带着他的孩子和妻子停了下来，他说，肖恩，你好吗，诸如此类的话。然后他不得不，我说，对不起，我没认出你来。当然，我已经有 40 多年没见过他了。而他正是我真正以此为原型的那个家伙，他的言谈变得非常清晰。
Right. Exactly. And in fact, in my own life at the time, I, you know, it is, you'd have to ask Cameron Crowe if this is the case, I'm sure I did, but I don't remember. My sense reading his book, which I read the book before the, a lot of people don't know that was a book before it was a screenplay. And I read that character and I felt that that was what he wrote rhythmically and so on.
他的眼神很清澈。他的为人父母看起来也非常清晰，这真的很非凡，但他至今都不知道那就是他，那就是一点点。你在小道上的那次碰面中没有告诉他吗？这听觉起来像是一个要扔给某人的重磅炸弹。你的爸爸是斯皮科利。我想我当时没说，因为你知道，可怜的家伙，接下来你就会看到记者跑去采访真正的斯皮科利并在他家里骚扰他。
And there was a guy who lived in my neighborhood who was a very close model for it. And in fact, about a year ago, I was walking up from a beach pass and a very straight looking gentleman with his kids and his wife stopped and he said, Sean, how are you? And so on and so forth. And then he had to, I said, I'm sorry, I'm not recognizing you. Of course, I hadn't seen him for over 40 years. And it was the fella that I really modeled the part on and he had his speech had become very clear.
嘿，肖恩，你有没有看到你在表演和导演方面真正喜欢做的事情——在感动和影响人们方面——与你通过慈善事业、通过做慈善所做的事情之间有任何相似之处？你所有的活动主义和——耶。它们来自同一个地方吗？这是我提出的比我计划的要短的第一个问题。干得好。
His eyes were clear. His parenting seemed very clear and it was really extraordinary, but he doesn't know to this day that it was him, that it was a little bit. You didn't tell him in that moment, in that meeting on the trail, that would seem like such a bomb to drop on someone. Your dad is Picoli. I think I didn't because you know, the poor guy, the next thing you know, you'd have journalists going over to interview the real Picoli and bothering him in his house.
顺便说一句，抱歉，在肖恩·潘回答之前，我们得庆祝一下杰森这次的问题有多短，这是第一次。操他。你们听够那些了吧，对吧？噢，真希望我们有个暗号，这样大家就能弄件连帽衫什么的。你知道我的意思吗？那太棒了。真他妈恭喜。
Hey, Sean, do you see any, do you see any parallel between what you really like to do with acting and directing as far as moving people and affecting people with what you do with your philanthropy, with your, with being charitable and- All your activism and- Yeah. Does it come from the same place? This is my first shorter question than I had planned. Good for you.
恭喜，贝特曼。肖恩，那个问题里的智慧够吗？我听懂了那个问题，我会这样回答：我出生于 1960 年，所以如果你算一下，那个我们作为青少年——甚至可以说是青春期——真正找到对电影的热情、当时制作的那些类型电影的时刻，对我来说，这是一个有幸被启蒙的时代。电影里有很多让人爱不释手的东西。而且在这些电影中，它们都以各自的方式，在没有成为激昂演说或任何东西的情况下，让人感觉
By the way, sorry, sorry before, Sean Penn, before you answer that, we got to celebrate how short Jason's question was for the first time. Fuck him. You guys got enough of that, right? Oh, I wish we had a code so people could get a hoodie or something. You know what I mean? That would be great. Fucking congrats.
非常有目标驱动力，我认为我们都在努力成为有目标驱动力的人，并且希望清楚地知道我们做事时为什么要做，以及什么时候做，我假设如果有相似之处，那仅仅是，你知道的，你想感到自己有生产力，你想觉得作为演员或电影制作人你在表达某些东西，你在参与表达一些有价值的东西，能够反映你所生活的时代，我认为这是任何人所做的任何事情的真实写照，你知道，涉足发展世界、应急响应、援助或无论人们想怎么称呼它。现在，我们在地球上正处于这样一个非常活跃的时期。
Congrats, Bateman. Sean, was that, was that enough intelligence in that question? I understood the question and I'll answer it this way, is I'm born in 1960, so if you do the math on that, that moment where we as young as adolescents really, I think, find our lust for film, the kinds of films that were being made at that time, it really was, in my sense, fortunate time to get turned on. There was a lot to fall in love with in film. And also within those films, they all in their ways without being polemics or anything, felt
你知道，我曾经想过，甚至对我而言，过着非常舒适的生活，也觉得每天天都要塌下来了，然后当我试图通过阿富汗人的眼睛或海地人的眼睛来想象这一点时，你知道，你知道，这个名单还在继续，这真的是难以想象的，所以对我来说，其中的目标就是捡起一些正在坠落的天空碎片，并试着把它们放回原位。这源于愤怒吗？这就像是——你应该看看宝贝们在奥扎克片场用完杏仁奶时的样子。
very, very purpose driven and I think we all strive to be purpose driven and want a clarity of why we're doing what we're doing when we're doing it and I suppose if there's a parallel that's simply that, you know, you want to feel productive, you want to feel you're saying something as an actor or as a filmmaker, you're participating in saying something that reflects in a valuable way on the time that you're living in and I think that that's true with anything that anyone does, you know, stepping out into the development world or emergency response or aid or whatever one wants to call it. Right now, we're in such an active time on the earth in this way.
我想那是同一种感觉，对吧，杰伊？我是说，这源于暴怒而非愤怒吗？是的。我认为这更像是暴怒。这源于一种感觉吗，比如当你读到正在发生的事情时——并且，听着，我不想，我们不是一个政治节目。我们不谈论，但就像，你知道，阿富汗正在发生的事情，让人觉得正在产生一个真空，其规模简直巨大。
You know, I thought, I think about how for even for me, with my very comfortable life, it seems the sky is falling every day and then when I try to imagine that through Afghani eyes or Haitian eyes and you know, you know, the list goes on, it's really unimaginable and so to the old, you know, for me to have purpose in that is to pick up some of the pieces of the sky that are falling and try to get them back in place. Does that come out of anger? Like is that like you should see baby when they run out of almond milk on the set of Ozark.
这真是太好了。这太他妈吓人和真实了。是那些时刻在晚上把你从床上惊醒，让你觉得，操，我得去那儿。我得做点什么。我不知道是不是那么明确。我会说，是的，有时我的，我自己的参与是由我愿意认为是一种同理心的事情交替驱动的。
I imagine it's the same sensation, right, Jay? I mean, does it come out of rage than anger? Yes. I think it's more rage. Does it come out of a sense like you feel that like, like when you read like what's going on and, you know, look, I don't want to, we're not a political show. We don't talk, but like, you know, what's going on in Afghanistan where it just feels like this vacuum is being created that is just of immense proportions.
我当然意识到这是一种暴怒，一种——就像任何自称是正义追求者的人一样虚伪，通常，你知道，我承认我有点正义狂，而现在并没有多少正义在发生。所以，但你谈到，就像，你知道的，从我舒适的生活出发，像，问题在这。每个人都期望，好吧，如果你想对那些事情感到愤怒并试图做出改变，那么你必须，你的生活必须绝对刀枪不入，经受得起任何形式的批评，你必须生活在你生活的每一个方面。
That's just good. That's so fucking scary and real. Are those those moments that bolt you up in bed at night and like, fuck, I got to get there. I got to do something. I don't know if it's that clear. I would say that, yes, there are times where it's alternately my, my own involvements are alternately driven by what I like to think is an empathy.
这就好像，不，操那个，老兄，我们都是竭尽所能的该死的人类。如果我们能在某些领域做得很好，并不意味着我们在其他所有该死的领域都是完美的。而且我认为当我们变得愤世嫉俗，以至于我们只想去关注他们的缺点而不是关注他们所做的事情时，我们就停止了赞美人们所做的事情。这就是一个，这就是我们现在生活的世界。而且存在着一种非常特定类型的愤世嫉俗。我认为。
What I'm certainly aware as a rage, a kind of as hypocritical as anybody who claims themselves a hunter for justice is typically, you know, I confess I'm a bit of a justice freak and there's not an awful lot of it going on right now. So, but you talk about like, you're like, you know, from my comfortable life, like, here's the problem. Everybody expects like, okay, well, if you want to be mad about that stuff and you want to try to make a difference, then you have to be, your life has to be absolutely impervious to any sort of criticism that you have to live every aspect of your life.
是的。我希望这不会在人们当中制造出一种活动主义的自我审查和自我意识，因为我们是勉强算得上合格的残缺机器。我的意思是，我是其中之一——当我们谈论时，你知道，有趣的是这种取消文化的理念是如何在党派界线上被认同的。但我们知道，伴随着所有的，你知道的思想演变，所有非常强大的理念以及剥洋葱般的方式，就我们如何能在这个世界上做得更好而言，它必须透过一个有瑕疵的镜头变得更好，如果它要成为合法的话。
And it's like, no, fuck that, man, we're all fucking human beings doing our best. And if we can do well in certain areas, it doesn't mean that we're perfect in every other fucking area. And I think we stop celebrating what people do when we're so cynical that all we want to do is instead of focusing on what they do, we focus on the shit on their shortcomings. And that is a, that is a world that, that's the world that we live in now. And it's a very specific type of cynicism that exists. I think.
而且，另一方面，要求完美机器的自我righteousness（自以为是）只是不可避免的伪善，因为，你知道，在那里，我想不出任何人，包括我自己，当你为某事骑上高头大马时，没有什么是别人同样可以把你拉下来摧毁你的。对。对。我们马上回来。
Yeah. And I hope that it doesn't create a self-censorship of activism among people and a self-consciousness about that because we are flawed machines that are at best. I mean, I'm one of the things when we talk about, you know, it's interesting how this idea of cancel culture has become identified with on partisan lines. But we know that with all of the, you know, evolution of thought, all of the very powerful ideas and the way the onion is being, you know, appealed back in terms of how we can do better in our world, there's, it's got to be better through a flawed lens if it's
现在，回到节目中。我确信你以前回答过这个问题，我为没有听到答案或记不清而道歉，但政治似乎会自然而然地吸引你。你离认真考虑涉足其中有多近？这是否会年复一年地波动？不，有一次，爱尔兰剧作家布伦丹·比安曾经说过，当被问到这个问题时。他说，我永远不能从政，因为我只有一张脸。
going to be legitimate. And the, and on the other side, the self-righteousness that is demanding perfect machines is, is just inevitable hypocrisy because, you know, there, I can't think of anybody, including myself, who when you get on a high horse about something, there's not something else someone can tear you down equally for. Right. Right. And we will be right back.
太棒了。我想，你知道，对我来说，抛开玩笑不谈，我只是认识到，比起作为一个政治领袖——我认为政治领袖需要把 24/7 的精力更多地放在为帮助人们的事物提供统一支持上，而不是像我这样经常发火——我以现在的方式做事，会拥有更有价值的气质，并对所做的事情给予更有价值的支持。肖恩，第一次是什么时候，当你变得——用一个不太恰当的词——开悟时？当你是一名演员，仅仅是一名演员时，有什么事件，或者有什么
And now, back to the show. I'm sure you've answered this before and I apologize for, for not having heard the answer or remembering it, but it seems like politics would be a natural pull for you and a draw for you. How, how close have you gotten to, to seriously considering jumping into that? And does that fluctuate from year to year? No, there was a, the Irish playwright, Brendan Bean, once said, he was asked that question. He said, I could never be in politics because I only have but one face.
事情让你觉得，等一下，我需要，这比我更大。我需要超越自我，真正作为一个人成长，并开始以那种方式奉献自己？是的，这对我来说很清楚，那是在成长过程中，我父亲在第二次世界大战期间在军队中以正式方式积极参与，然后也在国内以非正式的社会方式积极参与，并在饭桌上伴随着大量公民教育的讨论长大。你知道，那是存在的。所以当我开始在这个充满创造力的生活中前行时，有一段时间
That's fantastic. I think that, you know, for me with a joking aside, that I just recognize that I would have a much more valuable temperament and support of the things that, that I do the way that I'm doing it, then I would as a political leader, which I think takes a more of a 24 seven focus on unifying in support of things that are going to help people and not have those bouts of rage as, as, as often as, as, as I do. When was that first time, Sean, when you became for lack of a better word enlightened, when you, when you were an actor and just an actor, was there some, what was the event or what
你会发现，我发现自己对它视而不见，真的只是想了解表演是关于什么的，以及我作为演员能做什么，然后，随着时间的推移，在大约十年之后，我的第一个孩子出生了，一年之后，两年之后，三年之后，呃，9·11 发生了。我记得我女儿头发上系着一根小丝带，我带她去当地的一个汉堡摊。我当时在买一个汉堡和一些薯条，我只是看着她。这可能是在飞机撞击和所有噩梦发生的一两天后。
was the thing where you're like, wait a minute, I need, this is bigger than me. I need to step out of myself and really grow as a person and start offering myself in that way. Yeah, it's, it's pretty clear to me that it was growing up in a, my father had been active both in a formal way in the, in military during World War II and then also informally socially back at the state side and growing up with a lot of civics discussed at the table. You know, that was there. And so as I started making my way through this kind of creative life, there's a period
这件事真的深深震撼了我：在这么多方面，他们的世界将成为，你知道，我们以前从未想象过的事情。我认为这启动了齿轮。所以在 2002 年，我进行了第一次巴格达之行，2003 年再次前往，后一次是为《旧金山纪事报》撰稿。我认为这些接触——开始前往世界上那些合法和非法妖魔化的地区，或者那些人们，不仅想看看我们这里的头条新闻，还想看看他们的头条新闻，他们的
of time where you just have, find, I found I had just had blinders on for it and really just wanted to understand what acting was about and what I could do as an actor and then, and moving along through that then after about a decade of that, my first child was born and a year after that, two years after that, three years after that, uh, 9-11. And I remember my daughter had a little ribbon in her hair and I took her to with a local burger stand. I was grabbing a burger and some fries and I was just looking at her. This is probably a day or two after the planes and all of that nightmare.
人民怎么说。我认为所有这些都会把你带走。最后，是，呃，就，你知道，是什么导致了我的组织 CORE 的诞生，那是卡特里娜飓风袭击新奥尔良时发生的。我通过去那里发现，去那里伸出援手并不一定是在妨碍当局，事实上，当局会张开双臂欢迎他们能得到的任何援助。所以一旦我有了那种，你知道的，实践的“执照”，它就从那时起像滚雪球一样发展开来了。
And it just really landed on me how much their world was going to be, you know, something that we had never imagined before in so many ways. And I think that that kicked into gear. And so by 2002, I made my first trip to Baghdad, repeated that in 2003, the latter trip writing for the San Francisco Chronicle. And I think that those engagements beginning to travel parts of the world that were both legitimately and illegitimately demonized or people who were and wanting to see, you know, not just what our headlines said here, but what their headlines said, what their
耶。太棒了。嘿，肖恩，你是如何保持信息灵通的？我想这，呃，这远远超出了《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》、《卫报》、MSNBC 和 CNN 的范畴。你们是否有一群值得信赖的、呃、呃，你每周会和他们通电话的学者，呃，我是说，在你可以透露这些事情的范围内，呃，但是
people said. And I think all of that kind of carries you away. And then finally, it was, uh, they're in terms of, you know, what led to my organization core that happened when Katrina hit in New Orleans. And I found out by going down there that one wasn't necessarily in authorities way, uh, by going down to lend a hand in that, in fact, the authorities would embrace any hands they could get. And so once I sort of had that, you know, license to practice, uh, it just kind of snowballed
你给我的印象是那种拥有一定水平的信息量，而且好奇心极强的人，呃，我们所有人如果能有一些这种品质，都会做得更好。嗯，我会说，如果这种说法在任何程度上是真的，那主要是通过世界各地的一群朋友网络，他们对世界的运作方式有着前排的座位。你知道，我经常，呃，如果我自己与外交领域的人交谈，他们曾从事外交工作，并从这些其他国家的视角看过美国，你会发现无论
from there. Yeah. That's great. Hey, Sean, how do you stay informed? I imagine it's, it's, uh, it goes well beyond, uh, New York Times, Washington Post, Guardian, uh, MSNBC and CNN. Is there, is there a group of trusted, uh, uh, academics that you have kind of a weekly call with, um, I mean, to the extent that you can reveal any of this stuff, um, but
一个人是共和党人还是民主党人，在思想上有更多的共同点，但他们曾在那些世界旅行过，在那些世界工作过，在那些世界提供过服务，我认为你会得到一幅更全面的关于所发生事情的图景，因为我们这里有一种单一文化的倾向。呃，我的确花了很多时间观看主流新闻，收听，呃，收音机里的新闻，但我确实认为，那些被针对的事情，我能触及的事情，无论（我知道）我在哪里拥有我组织的资源等等，我需要深入了解事情的本质，那么这很大程度上依赖于在各个方面进行这些事情所需的联系网络。
it, you strike me as somebody that is, has got a level of, of information, um, and curiosity that, uh, we'd all do better to have some of. Well, I would say to the degree that, that to any degree that that is true, it is principally through a network of, of friends, um, around the world who have a front row seat to how the world works. You know, I often, uh, if I myself in conversation with people in, in foreign, who have worked in foreign service and have seen, uh, the United States, uh, through the, from the perspective of these other countries, and you will find a lot more commonality and thought whether
你谈到了 CORE，你的组织，他们拍了，呃，拍的那部纪录片是《公民潘》，对吧？关于 CORE 的。你能多谈谈 CORE 吗，比如你的日常工作是怎样的，你们的触及范围有多大？是的。所以，你知道，正如我们所知，我们迎来了这个，呃，可怕的，呃，地震再次袭击了海地南部。
somebody be Republican or Democrat, but that they have traveled in those, those worlds, worked in those worlds, offered service in those worlds, I think that you get a much fuller picture of what happens because we have just a kind of monocultural bent here. Um, I do spend a lot of time watching, uh, mainstream news, listening to, um, news on the radio, but I do think that the, that the things that, that are targeted, the things that I can touch, whether, you know, where I have the resources with my organization and so on, and I need to get to the depth of things, then that relies heavily on a network of, of contacts and all aspects of, of what it takes to do those things.
呃，我们的团队昨天进去了，呃，今天就有设备进去，医疗，你知道，与许多其他组织和组织负责人进行协调，呃，这是一个非常绝望的局势。从太子港运送物资的道路，呃，是，呃，被帮派控制的。所以通过海运、旋转翼或固定翼飞机以外的任何其他方式将物资运送到那里，存在着非常大的安全问题。那里有像我们所知道的那样运转的政府吗？不是我们所知道的那样，对吧？我是说，没有真正的基础设施。这，这难道除了地震造成的破坏之外的主要障碍之一吗？
And you talked about core, your, your organization, they made, um, was the documentary they made the citizen pan, right? About, about core. Can you talk a little bit about core, about like what that day to day is like for you and what kind of, what kind of reach you guys are having? Yeah. So, you know, as we know, we had this, uh, horrifying, um, earthquake hit again now in, in the south and in, in Haiti.
嗯，事情是这样的，在 2010 年，地震的震中就在太子港外面的莱甘。所以那把所有的政府部委都震塌了。所以字面意义上权力的中心崩溃了。所以没有可以打电话的人，因为他们，他们，已经遇难了。所以大部分政府都消失了。在这种情况下，呃，还有待观察，你知道，在这个后勤挑战和领导力挑战中，什么会更有效。
Um, our teams went in yesterday, uh, to have equipment in today, medical, you know, coordinating with a lot of other organizations and organizational leads and, um, it's a very desperate situation. The road that, uh, to get supply in from Port-au-Prince is, uh, is, uh, owned by gangs. And so that there's very big security issues getting supply there in any other way than C or rotary or fixed wing. Is there a functioning government as we, not as we know it, right? I mean, there's no real infrastructure. Is that, is that one of the main impediments apart from the destruction from the earthquake?
嗯，我们的团队昨天进去了，呃，今天要把设备运进去，医疗设备，你知道的，还要协调许多其他组织和组织负责人，嗯，这是一个非常绝望的局势。从太子港运送物资的那条路，呃，是被帮派控制的。因此，除了通过海运、直升机或固定翼飞机之外，通过其他任何方式将物资运送到那里都存在非常大的安全问题。这里有像我们所知道的那样正常运转的政府吗？没有，如我们所知，根本没有。我的意思是，这里没有真正的基础设施。除了地震造成的破坏之外，这难道、这难道也是主要的障碍之一吗？
Well, here's the thing that in 2010, the earthquake was epicentered and lay gone right outside of Port-au-Prince. And so that pancaked all the government ministries. So literally the seat of power collapsed. So there was, there was no one to call because they were, they were, they'd perished. And so most of government was gone. In this case, uh, and it will remain to be seen, you know, what's going to be more functional in this logistical challenge and leadership challenge.
嗯，情况是这样的，2010年那场地震的震中就在太子港郊外。这导致所有政府部门的大楼都像煎饼一样坍塌了。因此，权力核心字面上说就是崩塌了。当时根本找不到人来指挥，因为他们都已经遇难了。所以大部分政府机构都不复存在了。而在这次事件中，嗯，还有待观察，你知道的，在这场后勤挑战和领导力挑战中，究竟什么会更有效运作。
Um, you know, as, as I'm sure your listeners know a few weeks ago, the president was violently assassinated and in a, in a, in a commando raid on his house, clearly the country is very politically unstable. There had been a last couple of years, a lot of people displaced by criminal activity. Most of that criminal activity in Haiti is paid for activity. So you have, you know, young gangsters being exploited by heavy weights who are trying to push political buttons and, and, and, and you get a lot of paid violent activity and kidnapping and so on.
嗯，你知道，正如，如我确信听众们所知道的，几周前，总统在一次突袭他家的突击行动中遭到暴力暗杀，显然这个国家在政治上非常不稳定。在过去的几年里，有很多人因犯罪活动而流离失所。海地的大多数犯罪活动都是付酬的活动。所以你知道，年轻的黑帮分子被那些试图拨动政治心弦的大腕们利用，然后，然后，你就会看到很多有偿的暴力活动和绑架等等。
So it's a very challenging environment. And made the, you know, I think that when any of us that work in Haiti, we, we, you know, while there have been some in government that have really, you know, been champions and really fought for their country, we, you really find the hope in Haiti and in the, in the common people. So much is said of their resilience and it's something that you, it's just so palpable. Um, like I said in the beginning of this conversation, you know, when I say the idea of what, what it must, this world looked like through Haitian eyes, it wouldn't look the
所以这是一个非常具有挑战性的环境。并且让，你知道的，我认为在海地工作的我们当中的任何一个人，我们，我们，你知道，虽然政府里有一些人确实，你知道的，一直是捍卫者，真的为他们的国家奋斗，但你真正能在海地和普通民众身上找到希望。人们对他们的韧性赞不绝口，这是一种你，这是如此触手可及的东西。嗯，就像我在这次谈话开始时说的，你知道，当我提到通过海地人的眼睛看这个世界会是什么样子时，它看起来不会是
same to them as it does to us in the sense of, of hopelessness. They have a hope. They have, you know, a real strength of spirit. And so they'd have to write otherwise you, because the alternative is just collapse. Yeah. Right. I mean, fuck man. I, I'm going to take Sean's question.
对他们来说和对我们一样，那种绝望感。他们有希望。你知道，他们有一种真正的精神力量。所以他们必须以其他方式书写，否则你，因为另一种选择就是崩溃。是的。对吧？我是说，见鬼，伙计。我要接肖恩的问题。
What do you do for fun, Sean? I was just going to go there. I was being kind of glib, but what, what do you do for fun? Like, what do you do in a world that I get it? There, there's so much. What are the things that do bring you, I know you get a lot of joy in a lot of, and to help out and be so active, but what are the things when you just want to fucking shut it down? Hmm.
肖恩，你平时有什么爱好？我正要说到这。我刚才有点轻率，但是，你平时有什么爱好？比如，在一个我觉得——这有太多了。有哪些事情能给你带来，我知道你在很多事情中找到了很多快乐，并且乐于助人而且非常活跃，但是当你只想他妈的好好放松一下时，你会做什么？嗯。
Well, I guess on the, on the static side, I like to write on, on the active side. I love, I've always been a surfer and loved surfing. I have done less of it in the last couple of years with all that's been going on than at, than at any other time in my life. And I even, you know, each morning as I wake up these days, it's like, is this the day I'm going to get back in the water? And I, and I, and turning 61 next week, I had better get back in the water. So you're going to, you're going to do it.
嗯，我想在静态方面，我喜欢写作，在动态方面，我喜欢，我一直是个冲浪爱好者并且热爱冲浪。在过去几年里，随着发生的一切，我冲浪的时间比我一生中的任何其他时期都要少。甚至，你知道，这些天我每天早上醒来时，都会想：今天是我能回到水里的一天吗？而且我，而且我，下周就要61岁了，我最好还是回到水里去。所以你打算，你打算去做了。
Listen, we're going to come over, we're going to celebrate. We're going to bring some E. We're going to go back to like year 2000. We're all four of us are going to do E and we're just going to fucking let it all hang out. Oh my God. Let our shoulders drop. Both of those things, writing and surfing sound, sound, sound pretty, pretty, pretty sane and responsible.
听着，我们要过去，我们要庆祝。我们要带点摇头丸。我们要回到2000年那会儿。我们四个全都要嗑摇头丸，然后我们要他妈的好好放纵一下。哦天哪。让我们紧绷的肩膀放松下来。这两件事，写作和冲浪，听起来，听起来，听起来都挺理智也挺负责任的。
Are you, what's the stupidest shit that you're doing? I mean, like, is it like a bad reality TV show? Is it like driving fast? Is it eating cookies and cake? I mean, like, what, what, what's the idiot part of you doing? Well, I think that, you know, you, you can, you can watch too much cable news. There's no question about that. Jason.
你在，你做过的最蠢的事是什么？我是说，比如是个糟糕的真人秀节目吗？还是像开快车？是吃饼干和蛋糕吗？我是说，你身上的白痴部分在干什么？嗯，我觉得，你知道，你，你可以看太多有线电视新闻。毫无疑问，杰森。
Yeah. And it can, because I think that there's, there's a thing we have called the nervous system that we want to protect. Yeah. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. I literally, so Sean, you need to know.
是的。而且它会，因为我觉得，我们体内有一个叫做神经系统的东西，我们需要保护它。是的。没错。是的。是的。我真的，所以肖恩，你需要知道。
So last week we were out East and we just got back, but last week we were out East and Jason and his wife and the kids came and stayed with us and me and my boys. And so Jason and I are both early risers and he would come, he'd come in and like, I'd be making a coffee and taking the dog out and stuff and Jason come in like 637. And the first, before he even turns on the coffee machine, he turns on the fucking cable news, which I never do. I stopped a long time ago because it makes me feel bad. Yeah.
所以上周我们在东海岸，我们刚回来，但上周我们在东海岸，杰森和他的妻子还有孩子们来和我们住在一起，还有我和我的男孩们。所以杰森和我都是早起的人，他会过来，他会进来，比如，我正在煮咖啡、带狗出去散步之类的，杰森会在6点37左右进来。首先，甚至在打开咖啡机之前，他就打开了他妈的有线电视新闻，而我从不看这个。我很早就停看了，因为它让我感觉不好。是的。
Right. And I was like, oh, I got to protect the way I feel. It's like turning the light on in the room. He turns it on and it's on all day and we're out on the East coast and it's a beautiful day. And he wants to go and do all this stuff, but he needs the soundtrack that is eating away at his... Well, where it makes you feel bad, it makes me feel good that these incredible journalists
对。然后我就想，哦，我得保护我的感受。这就好像打开房间里的灯一样。他把它打开，然后一整天都开着，我们在东海岸，天气好极了。他想去这去那，但他需要那个不断侵蚀他……嗯，既然它让你感觉不好，它却让我感觉很好，这些不可思议的记者
from my preferences, MSNBC, where these guys are shaping these opinions and articulating them in such a way where it helps a dumb, dumb like me kind of get it out. And I like the way they take down some of these nincompoops that they're having to work, you know, next to and alongside. And it releases my valve. We have to bleep that out with the nincompoop. We're going to have to beep it and then everything gets... Jesus fuck.
按照我的喜好，MSNBC（微软全国广播公司），这些家伙在塑造这些观点并以某种方式表达出来，这有助于像我这样的笨蛋能够理解。而且我喜欢他们痛打那些他们不得不，你知道的，在旁边和一起工作的笨蛋们的方式。它释放了我的压力阀。我们得把那个“笨蛋”给消音。我们得发出哔哔声，然后一切都变得……真他妈见鬼。
What the fuck is this? Like the fifties? What are you doing? Sean, back to Will's suggestion of us taking E and going surfing. Okay. Well, let's make it mushrooms. Let's make it mushrooms. Mushroom mushrooms.
这他妈算什么？就像五十年代一样？你在干什么？肖恩，回到威尔关于我们嗑摇头丸去冲浪的建议。好吧。那我们换成迷幻蘑菇吧。换成迷幻蘑菇吧。蘑菇，蘑菇。
Anyway. It's next week on his 64th birthday. Yeah, go ahead. I mean, having played one of the most famous donors ever in the history of the world, what is like the worst drug trip you've ever been on? What is that? Well, it's funny. When I played that part, I had never done any drug at all and didn't until after that.
不管怎样。下周就是他64岁生日了。是的，继续。我是说，既然你扮演过世界历史上最著名的捐助者之一，你经历过的最糟糕的药物旅行是什么？那是什么？嗯，挺有意思的。当我扮演那个角色时，我从来没吸过任何毒品，直到那之后才开始。
But for sure, the worst was I had taken a 21 hour drive direct from New York to New Orleans, checked into a hotel and thought, okay, it's a good idea to get something to eat before I go to bed. It was about 11 o'clock at night. Make a long story short. I walked into a bar where I got dosed seven hits of liquid acid and went on a 35 hour relentless trip to hell. That's not, that's not an experience I'd like to repeat.
但肯定的，最糟糕的一次是我从纽约直接开了21个小时的车到新奥尔良，入住了一家酒店，心想，好吧，睡觉前吃点东西是个好主意。当时大概是晚上11点。长话短说。我走进了一家酒吧，在那里我被下了七剂液体迷幻酸，并经历了一场长达35小时的无休止的地狱之旅。那不是，那不是我想重复的经历。
Worst place to do it to, what a fucking nightmare. Oh man. Yeah, that's a, that's a place you just can't get out of. You feel like you're, you feel like you're broken, that you're never going to come back, right? Yeah. Yeah. Oh buddy.
去那儿做这事简直是最糟糕的地方，真他妈是一场噩梦。哦天哪。是的，那是一个，那是一个你根本无法摆脱的地方。你觉得自己，你觉得自己崩溃了，你永远也回不去了，对吧？是的。是的。哦，老兄。
Like in, in, in that sort of, in that emergency time, like every, your boots on the ground, you get there and everything's, the world's falling apart. And then like some local there is like, Spicoli's here, we're okay. Like, you know what I mean? Like, has that ever happened? Have you ever had a weird moment, like in a desperate time? It hasn't. Well, the only, you know, the only place, for example, in Haiti, there's, when prior
就像在，在那种，在那种紧急时刻，就像每个人，你的靴子踩在地上，你到了那里，然后一切都，世界正在分崩离析。然后就像那里的某个当地人说，斯皮科利在这儿，我们没事。就像，你知道我的意思吗？就像，这种事发生过吗？你在绝望的时候有过什么奇怪的时刻吗？没有。嗯，唯一，你知道，唯一的地方，比如在海地，当之前
to 2010, if they saw movies at all, movie theaters came collapsed in 2010, there were too much, they were interested in the Rambos and action movies. And so you never got any distribution of the films that, kind of films that I'd done. You didn't have a lot of people with laptop computers watching things. It was nothing like that. So I don't have a high visibility at all in Haiti, even today as an actor. Interesting. The only, I'm going to say exotic place where I was taken off guard by that kind of recognition
在2010年之前，如果他们还能看到电影的话，电影院在2010年倒塌了，他们看过太多，他们对《第一滴血》（Rambo）和动作片感兴趣。所以你根本无法发行我所拍的那种电影。你没有很多人拿着笔记本电脑看东西。根本没有那种事。所以我在海地没有很高的知名度，即使今天作为一个演员也是如此。很有趣。唯一一个，我要说的是让我对这种认可感到措手不及的异国他乡
was forgive me not being able to come up with the year, but it was in the week preceding the election called that appointment of Ahmadinejad in Iran. And I'd gone again for the San Francisco Chronicle to write a piece on that election. And typically when I go to a place that's really new to me, I like to, depending upon what time that airplane lands, I like to get up very early in the morning and just take a long walk to kind of absorb the place. And I had had, and I wrote about this, the kind of sense of Iran as this sort of doom and gloom and chant place, which we'd heard all we'd heard about here in the States.
请原谅我想不起具体是哪一年了，但那是在伊朗被称为任命内贾德的那场选举前的一周。我当时也是为了《旧金山纪事报》去写一篇关于那场选举的文章。通常情况下，当我到一个对我很陌生的地方时，我喜欢，取决于那架飞机降落的时间，我喜欢一大早起床，然后散步很久，来感受这个地方。我曾有过，我写过这个，伊朗那种厄运重重、充满吟唱的地方的感觉，我们在美国听到的都是这些。
And in fact, the people were so hip, they were so aware of American movies. I think the first thing that they talked to me about was 21 Grams, which had the most sex and drugs of any movie I probably ever did. And they were, you know, we love that movie. So that was the most surprising, the people there are extraordinary. Clearly they have a horror show and leadership, but there are, you know, really extraordinary people in Iran. So Sean, you turning 61, us kind of right on your heels, if you're like us or me at
而事实上，那里的每个人都如此时髦，他们对美国电影非常了解。我想他们和我谈论的第一件事就是《21克》，那可能包含了我拍过的电影中最多的性和毒品。他们，你知道的，我们太喜欢那部电影了。所以那是最大的一处惊喜，那里的人们非同寻常。显然他们的领导层是一场恐怖秀，但伊朗确实有一些，你知道的，非常非凡的人。所以肖恩，你马上61岁了，我们紧随其后，如果你和我们一样，或者至少和我有同感
least, you know, we're halfway, right? Let's say. I mean, are you living to a hundred? Sorry, we've never talked about this. You're living to a hundred. I'm shooting for it. Fuck. Do you start thinking about, well, all four of us have been very fortunate that we've
你知道的，我们走了一半了，对吧？姑且这么说吧。我是说，你能活到一百岁吗？抱歉，我们从来没聊过这个。你能活到一百岁吗？我正朝着这个目标努力。真他妈的。你开始思考，好吧，我们四个都非常幸运，我们
gotten a lot of things done that we probably wanted to get done. Certainly Sean, you seem to have done so many great things. Do you think about this, the second half, does something jump to the front of your mind is something you really want to get done before it's all over? You know, it's, my wife is a significantly younger woman than I am a man, and she doesn't have much tolerance for me considering that I'm on the second half. So publicly, I don't know what I'll say about that. But yes, certainly.
完成了许多我们可能想要完成的事情。当然是肖恩，你似乎做了那么多伟大的事情。你考虑过这个，下半场，有什么东西会一下子浮现在你的脑海里，成为你在这一切结束之前真正想完成的事情吗？你知道，我的妻子比我年轻很多，对于我考虑自己正处于下半场这件事，她并没有太多的容忍度。所以公开地说，我不知道我会对此说些什么。但当然，确实如此。
Sean just looked over his shoulder, by the way, certainly one wants to, you know, I guess I measure it trying to be a better dad every day and make sure that I'm, that I, on the last day, I have as little shame as possible. Yeah, I get that. Yeah, I get that too. I remember, I remember, I don't know, when was the last time you talked about Falcon and the Snowman? Was it been a minute?
顺便说一句，肖恩刚刚看了看他的肩膀，当然一个人会，你知道的，我想我是通过每天努力做一个更好的爸爸来衡量这件事，并确保在最后一天，我尽可能少地感到羞耻。是的，我懂。是的，我也懂。我记得，我记得，我不知道，你们最后一次聊起《猎鹰与雪人》是什么时候？有一会儿了吧？
Been a minute, yeah. Yeah. I remember that movie. I remember that movie, man. I was like, I'm 10 years, I'd like Jason, I'm about 10 years younger than you. And I remember that movie came out, I was about 14, and I was like, fuck, that's so fucking cool. Talk to me a little bit about that.
有一会儿了，是的。是的。我还记得那部电影。我还记得那部电影，伙计。我当时就像，我10岁，我想像杰森一样，我比你小大约10岁。我记得那部电影上映时，我大概14岁，当时我就想，操，太酷了。跟我多聊聊那个吧。
Because I remember, that was right around, like that was, who, who, I forget who directed that film. It was John Slesinger. Oh. Yeah, it was such a, it was such a sophisticated movie, in a way. Like it was a, it was a really, you know, that's a true film as opposed to movie. That's one of those movies that I think I reserved the word for. But I mean, that was a great movie.
因为我记得，那大约是，就像那是，谁，谁，我忘了是谁导演的那部电影。是约翰·施莱辛格。哦。是的，那是一部，从某种意义上说是一部非常成熟的电影。就像它是一部，你知道的，那才是一部真正的电影，而不是普通的影片。那是我想保留这个词的电影之一。但我是说，那是一部伟大的电影。
Can you talk, was that a good experience for you that movie? John was an extraordinary film director, you know. He had made Midnight Cowboy, Marathon Man, The Day of the Locust, Far From the Matting Crowd. I mean, he, he, he was, and he was very diverse. He also directed opera, theater. And so I walked into that movie as a gigantic fan. And in the period after making the movie, John and I got along great.
你能聊聊吗，那部电影对你来说是一次很好的经历吗？约翰是一位非凡的电影导演，你知道的。他拍过《午夜牛郎》、《马拉松人》、《蝗虫之日》、《远离尘嚣》。我是说，他，他，他，而且他非常多才多艺。他还导演过歌剧、戏剧。所以我作为一个超级粉丝走进了那部电影。在拍完电影的那段时间里，我和约翰相处得非常好。
We didn't have a good relationship during the making of the film because there was a sort of, I had a real devotion to bringing the character out very much in line, which would not always be the case. But in that case, very much as, as close as I could get to who, who the real guy was. And by that, I mean, you know, physically, vocally, all of it. And John was interested in a more impressionistic view of it. So we kind of, like, butted heads a little bit. Yeah, but it heads a little bit on that.
我们在拍电影的过程中关系并不是很好，因为某种程度上，我对把这个角色刻画得非常符合真实原型有一种真正的执着，而这并不总是能做到。但在那种情况下，尽可能地接近那个真实的人是谁。我的意思是，从外表、声音到方方面面。而约翰对它有更印象派的看法。所以我们有点，有点针锋相对。是的，在那上面有点针锋相对。
But that said, you know, to be whatever I was about 22, 23 years old, and to have the opportunity to work with John Slesinger and Alan Davio, and, and then my, my great friend, Timothy Hutton, on the second thing that we did together, you know, it's a very memorable one. And also Steve Zellian, who wrote the script, who was down there. And we shot most of the film in Mexico City. And so even that part of it, being able to spend time in Mexico, which I'd only ever gotten down to Rosarito before with a surfboard and never, never been down in Mexico City
但话虽如此，你知道，无论我当时是22岁还是23岁左右，能有机会与约翰·施莱辛格和阿兰·达维奥合作，然后还有我的好朋友蒂姆·赫顿，这是我们合作的第二部作品，你知道的，这是一部非常难忘的作品。还有史蒂夫·泽里安，他写了剧本，他也去了那里。我们在墨西哥城拍摄了大部分电影。所以即使是那一部分，能够有机会在墨西哥呆上一段时间，我以前只和冲浪板去过罗萨里多，在此之前从来没有去过墨西哥城
before that. And it was quite a great experience. And that was right. Of course, you and Timothy Hutton had done tabs together. And then this was you guys together. I remember it's always, I've always remembered the, you know, because there was a lot of press about it back even way back then that you guys were great friends and then you guys went and did this film.
而且这是一次非常棒的经历。那是当然的。你和蒂姆·赫顿当然一起合作过《军校风云》。然后这是你们两个一起合作。我记得，我一直都记得，你知道的，因为当时有很多关于你们是好朋友然后一起去拍这部电影的报道，甚至在那个时候也是如此。
I don't know. It's just always style. I always loved that movie. There's no real question there other than I just love that fucking movie. It's also what I, I do have nostalgia when I hear that the David Bowie Patton and Matheny track. Oh, yes. Not America from now.
我不知道。就是一直很有范儿。我一直很喜欢那部电影。除了我就是喜欢那部他妈的电影之外，并没有真正的问题。还有，当我听到大卫·鲍伊、帕特和梅西尼的那首曲目时，我确实有一种怀旧感。哦，是的。现在的《非美国》。
So good. We'll be right back. Sean, where do you stand on that going back to the, to you having a conversation, a creative negotiation with the, with the director? Where do you stand on that, especially now having, having directed since you went through that situation with Schlesinger, where do you stand on whose character is it? Is it the actor's character or is it the director's character? And how have you found your, your flexibility, adjusting, are you trying to start a fight?
太棒了。我们马上回来。肖恩，对于回到你刚才说的——你与导演进行对话、进行创意谈判这件事，你的立场是什么？你对此持什么立场，尤其是在你经历了施莱辛格的那种情况之后，现在你也当了导演，你对“谁的角色是谁的”持什么立场？这是演员的角色还是导演的角色？你发现你的灵活性、适应性如何，你是想挑起一场争端吗？
What are you trying to, what are you trying to get him going? But I just, I mean, I, you know, I, well, I'll let you answer it. I won't answer my own question. Go ahead. Well, I think it cuts both ways because, you know, in my sense of working in the theater is that the director's principal job is to wean the actor out of dependence on the director. You know, you've got to, at some point, let those horses run together once they've got their coordinated interests in line to tell the story.
你想干什么？你想挑起他的火气吗？但我只是，我是说，我，你知道，好吧，我让你来回答吧。我不回答我自己的问题。请吧。嗯，我觉得这可以说是双向的，因为，你知道，在我对戏剧工作的理解中，导演的主要工作是让演员摆脱对导演的依赖。你知道的，一旦他们的协调利益一致来讲述这个故事，你在某个时刻就必须让那些马一起奔跑。
In film, it's different, but I think that if you're not able to let the actor own that character, then you probably cast the wrong actor. Now, there's, there's variances on that where there are times where, you know, a director may understand and be able to push you to another level of the same gap or to make you, you know, revisit some of the choices that you made. But you do, you certainly want that, that the guiding energy on a set is that that actor speaks for that, that character. You can, I think as an, as an actor, we're kind of the designated bodyguard of the character
在电影中情况则不同，但我认为如果你不能让演员拥有那个角色，那你可能选错了演员。现在，这其中也有一些差异，有时候，你知道，导演可能会理解并能够把你推向同一个差距的另一个高度，或者让你，你知道的，重新审视你所做出的一些选择。但是你确实，你当然希望在片场有一种指导性的能量，即那个演员是在为那个角色发声。我认为作为，作为演员，我们有点像是我们所扮演的角色的指定保镖。
we're playing. Hmm. Yeah. And, and I, I mean, you know, it's the challenge comes with, you know, people who are given a part as opposed to audition for a part, and so you don't really know what that actor is going to do, what the version of that character they're going to be performing until it's about 20 minutes from shooting. You're saying it sucks to work with stars.
嗯。是的。而且，我的意思是，你知道，挑战来自于，你知道的，那些被分配角色而不是试镜角色的人，所以你真的不知道那个演员会做什么，他们将要表演的那个角色会是什么版本，直到开拍前大约20分钟。你是说和明星合作糟透了？
Well, you know, you, you kind of, a lot of directors have to kind of take what they get. And if you're a director like me, that's a good thing because I, I've got a real light touch with actors. I love, I just assume, and they're going to give me the best that they can give. And then your job is to see, well, okay, what version do they want to play of this character? And I got to help them kind of keep it on the, on the road. Whereas, you know, I'll work with some directors where the, all their notes, you get the sense all their notes are coming from a place of boy, how am I going to get this actor to play
嗯，你知道的，你有点，很多导演不得不接受他们得到的。如果你是一个像我这样的导演，这是一件好事，因为我对演员的态度非常轻松。我喜欢，我只是假定，他们会给我他们能给出的最好的东西。然后你的工作就是看看，好吧，他们想扮演这个角色的哪个版本？我得帮他们把这个保持在正确的轨道上。然而，你知道，我会和一些导演合作，他们的所有的笔记，你会觉得他们所有的笔记都来自这样一个地方：天哪，我该怎么让演员按照我在整个前期制作中一直设想的那样去扮演这个角色？
the part the way that I've seen it all the way through pre-production. You want to first read the script or developing it with the writer or whatever. And that's just to me, that's a, just a false negative that a director will put on an actor because the audience hasn't read the script they've got, they don't have the preconceived notion that director has. And now you're asking the actor to go into areas that they're not instinctually driven towards and it's, it can yield a real clanky thing. So it's great to hear you say that.
你首先想阅读剧本或与编剧一起开发剧本等等。对我来说，这只是导演强加给演员的一种虚假的否定，因为观众没有读过他们手头上的剧本，他们没有导演那种先入为主的观念。现在你却要求演员去他们本能并不想去的领域，这可能会产生一种真正的生硬感。所以听到你这么说真是太好了。
There's a kind of, you know, approach that is, you know, a win and doubt, do nothing approach that sometimes frames this conversation for me. I once had a conversation with Marlon Brando where he said this great thing, because there've been plenty of times where just notwithstanding being an actor or a director, as a film audience, there are plenty of times where I was so moved by something an actor did and then going back, I, I'm watching it again, I still so moved, I couldn't find what the actor did and sometimes, as Marlon said, when you have good writing, when you have good directing, sometimes the job is not getting in the audience's way, that they will do a lot of the work of how
有一种，你知道的，方法是，你知道的，“有疑问时，什么也不做”的方法，有时它为我和这种对话定下了基调。我曾与马龙·白兰度有过一次谈话，他说了一件很棒的事，因为有很多次，抛开身为演员或导演不谈，作为电影观众，有很多次我被演员的某个举动深深打动，然后回过头去，我再次观看它时，我依然如此感动，但我却找不到演员究竟做了什么，有时，正如马龙所说，当你拥有好的剧本，当你拥有好的导演时，有时的工作就是不要挡住观众的路，他们会自己去完成很大一部分关于这个故事是如何自我讲述的工作。因此，所有这些方法，我确实认为，那些拒绝给自己带来被演员带来的东西所惊艳的机会的导演，是对自己和项目的一种损害。但有时，你知道的，情况会来回反复，那就是，你可以从一个好导演那里获得大量的指导。你想不想回去拍一部又大又俗的喜剧？就拍一部又大又蠢的、关于抢劫的烂喜剧。
that story is telling itself. And so all of these approaches, I do think that, you know, directors who, who deny themselves the ability to be surprised by what their actors bring are doing themselves in the project of disservice. But there are times that, you know, that it goes back and forth, that it's just a, that you can, you can get a lot of guidance from a good director as well. Do you ever want to go back and do a big, fat comedy? Just do one big, stupid, heisty, bad comedy.
你知道的，我没有收到很多这类邀约。真的吗？真的吗？是的，我想随着我年龄的增长，我的脸变得越来越让人不安，而喜剧成分却越来越少。我不知道为什么，但我只是，你知道，当我有机会演喜剧时，我真的很享受，但是，而且，当然我对喜剧的兴趣和对任何其他事情的兴趣一样大。
You know, I have not been offered a lot of those. Really? Really? And, yeah, I think as I got older, my face became more disturbing and less than the amount of comedy. I don't know what it is, but I just, I haven't, you know, when I've gotten to do a comedy, I've really enjoyed it, but, but, and, and certainly I would be as interested in the comedy as I would in anything.
肖恩·海斯，你，你觉得你以后还会演喜剧吗？你知道的，我知道我们会问这个，所以谢谢你。这得看情况。这只取决于它讲的是什么以及我能把那个家伙挖掘得多深。你知道我刚刚在想什么吗？肖恩现在一定正在享受其中，因为我们问了所有这些非常重要的问题，然后我们一直说，接着问肖恩，然后海斯有一小会儿有那么几纳秒的时间心想：他们在问我吗？他们认识我吗？
Sean Hayes, do you, do you think you'll ever do a comedy? You know, I knew we were going to ask that, so thank you. It just depends. It just depends on what it's about and how deep I can find that guy. You know what I was just thinking? Sean must be just basking in, because we're asking all these really important questions, then we keep saying, and then asking Sean, and then Hayes for a moment has these nanoseconds where he's like, they're asking me and do they know me?
我们已经是20年的老朋友了，当然认识。对吧？我从来没有被问过这么深刻的问题。但是你知道的，所以，肖恩·潘，你现在，就像你说的，你61岁了，对于一个自称处于下半场之类的人来说，你手头有很多事情要做。你看不到，没有那种，我的意思是，我有点觉得这是胡扯，你现在正是状态火热的时候，比以往任何时候都做得更多。
And we've been friends for 20 years, wise, yes. Right. I never get asked those deep questions. But you know, so, so Sean Pan, you're, now you've got, like you say, you're 61 and you've got a lot on your plate for, for a guy who claims that he's in the, the sort of the second half or whatever. You don't see, there's no kind of, I mean, I kind of call BS, you're, you're kind of right in your zone right now, kind of doing it all more than ever.
听众朋友，你们得知道，我们现在正看着这家伙，这个肖恩·潘，这家伙看起来状态相当火爆，肖恩，什么情况？秘诀是什么？首先，宝贝想知道，秘诀是什么？是的。哦，你是在说我看起来怎么样吗？对。是的。
Listener, you got to know, we're, we're looking at this guy right now, this Sean Pan, this, this guy is pretty smoking guys, Sean, what's, what's, what's going on? What's the secret? First of all, Baby wants to know, what's the secret? Yeah. Oh, are you talking about how I look? Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，秘诀在于构图和光线。不，不，那里没有环形灯。什么都没有。我是说，你看上去疯狂地健康。你跟莱尔德（Laird）混在一起吗？我是说，这到底是怎么回事？现在，我希望我能重新开始，重回疫情后的健身状态，我已经开始了这项工作，但也仅仅是刚开始。
Well, the secret is framing and light. No, no, there's no, there's no ring light there. There's nothing. I mean, you look crazy healthy. Are you hanging out with Laird a bunch? I mean, what's going on? Now, I wish I was getting myself back into a post COVID fitness has commenced that I've begun that work, but only begun it.
那是什么？对你来说那是什么样的锻炼？嗯，主要是从在路上或跑步机上跑步开始。然后一旦我把自己，你知道的，跑累了，我就会从跑步机上或路上跳下来，开始进行负重训练，并尽量在过程中少抽几根烟。听众朋友，你们要知道，他从来没有不手里拿过烟。我不会承认我抽烟。
What is that? What is that workout for you? Well, mostly it starts with running either on the road or on a treadmill. And then once I've got myself, you know, run out and I'll jump off that treadmill or off the road into a weight workout and try not to smoke as many cigarettes on the, in the course. And listener, just so you know, he hasn't never had, not had a cigarette in his hand. I won't admit to, to smoking.
我不会承认的，但我支持你。我称之为肿瘤科医生的就业保障。哦，天哪。别这么说。等等，肖恩，你现在在看什么？你，你喜欢流媒体的东西吗？你平时做什么？还是你对这些根本不感兴趣？
I won't admit to it, but I'm with you. I call it job security for oncologists. Oh my God. Don't say that. Wait, Sean, what are you watching right now? Do you, do you enjoy a streaming thing? What do you do? Or you don't, you want anything to do with it?
所以你转而听音乐？哦，是的。我刚看了《灵魂乐暑期节》（Summer of Soul），如果有人还没看过的话，那真是太不可思议了。是的，真的很不可思议。那是什么？那是奎斯特洛夫（Questlove）的电影。对。
So you listen to music instead? Oh yeah. I just saw a summer of soul, which is incredible if anybody hadn't seen it. Yes. Really incredible. What is that? That's Questlove's movie. Right.
是的。我会去看那个的。哦，是的。是的。太棒了。令人兴奋。在电影制作层面上，以及在故事层面上，它确实是一部了不起的作品。我很渴望《继承之战》（Succession）重新开播。
Yeah. I'll see that. Oh yeah. Yeah. That's amazing. I'm thrilling. On a filmmaking level and on, and the story, it really was something. I'm anxious for succession to start back up.
哦，太好了。当然。当然。我有时会想不起来。哦，我刚看了，凯特·温丝莱特在那部剧里演得太棒了。东城梦魇（Mare of Easttown）。是的，完全正确。是的。
Oh, nice. Sure. Sure. And I'll blank on things. Oh, I just saw, Kate Winslet was just so great in this thing. Mayor of Eastwood. Yes, exactly. Yeah.
所以我会，我尽量不被这些东西迷住，因为，你知道的，我对这种成瘾的东西可能和任何人一样容易受到影响，但我从来没有陷进去，因为我把它推迟了。直到新冠疫情期间我才看流媒体节目。我妻子带我接触了一些。你觉得怎么样？你觉得它怎么样？它是一种媒介。你喜欢它吗？
So I will, I try not to get hooked by these things because, you know, I'm pretty susceptible to that addiction probably as anybody, but never, never got there because I put it off. I didn't see a streaming show until COVID. My wife turned me on to something. What do you think? What do you think about it? It's a medium. How do you like it?
嗯，我不喜欢它对电影所做的事情。我认为有这样一种东西，你知道，任何创造更多接触机会的事情，使电影制作平权化，赋予我们更多样性，能够看到来自世界各地的电影。这有很好的一面。但就像任何事实上的城镇广场一样，如果它变得太拥挤，那么你就，什么都不是特别的，而且会有很多尖锐的手肘。是的。所以我对此感到非常纠结。
Well, I don't like what it's doing to film. I think that there's something, you know, anything that creates more contact, democratizes the ability to make film, gives us more diversity, being able to see film from all over the world. That's got a great part to it. But like any de facto town square, if it gets too crowded, then you just, nothing special and it gets to be a lot of sharp elbows. Yeah. And so I'm very torn about it.
如果我们这些从事表演和电影制作的人能够站起来对我们的金融金主说，你知道，如果我们要做其他这些事情，你们必须保留电影的独家院线发行权，那我就会不那么纠结了。我很想看到这样一场运动。但作为一个电影人，我想我就是爱上了电影这个女孩，那个巨大的黑暗房间。所以I don't know that I would want to work as a director to that end, but I certainly can get caught up as an audience and there's some miraculous work that's being done on television. 毫无疑问。
I would be less torn about it if we in acting and filmmaking stood up to our financial lords and said, you know, you have to preserve exclusive theatrical releases of films if we are to do this other stuff. I would like to see that movement. But there is something as a filmmaker, I think I just fell in love with the girl that was is the cinema, the big dark room. So I don't know that I would want to work as a director to that end, but I certainly can get caught up as an audience and there's some miraculous work that's being done on
贝特曼，你毁了电影，贝特曼，然后肖恩·潘刚刚证实了这一点，我站在他这边。顺便说一句，应该指出的是，不管肖恩·潘的观点是什么，这也是我的观点。这一点应该被指出。我附议。请吧，宝贝。
television. There's no question about it. Bateman, you ruined film Bateman and then Sean Penn just confirmed it and I'm with him. And by the way, it should be noted, whatever Sean Penn's opinion is, is also my opinion. It should just be noted. I second that. Go ahead, baby.
请吧。我附议。那么——听众朋友们，他的右肩上方有一把吉他，在这个世界上，音乐对你来说处于什么位置？它是一种爱好吗？是一种激情吗？是你的下一份事业吗？它对你有什么作用？
Go ahead. I second that. What about so the listener, there's a guitar over his right shoulder and where does music sit for you in this world? Is it a hobby? Is it a passion? Is it your next career? What's it do for you?
这是我无法做到的激情所在。那是我的儿子。我儿子的一把吉他。我是个糟糕的吉他手。如果我唱歌，你们都会死掉。对我来说最好的良药是听音乐。在电影中，我是一个非常依赖音乐的导演。再次回到我成长的那个时代，无论是《毕业生》（The Graduate）还是《哈罗德和毛德》（Harold and Maude），或者那些将歌曲作为讲故事的一部分或作为故事中的角色的电影。我对那种电影有着极大的喜爱。
It's the passion that I can't do. That's my son. One of my son's guitars. I am terrible guitar player. If I sang, you'd all be dead. It is the thing that's the best medicine for me is listening to music. I'm a very music dependent director in film. Again going back to that era that I grew up in, whether it was the graduate or Harold
而且我喜欢和音乐家合作。我有过一些非常棒的合作，超级丰富。跟我讲讲在最后一部电影中和埃迪·韦德（Eddie Vedder）合作的经历吧。我是他超级、超级大的粉丝，而且我知道你们关系很近。那是什么感觉？
Mott or those films that used songs as part of the storytelling or as characters in the story. I have a great affection for that kind of cinema. And I love working with musicians. I've had some really great collaborations that have been super enriching. Tell me about working with Eddie Vedder on the last film. I'm such a huge, huge fan of his and I know you guys are close. What was that like?
嗯，埃德和我过去在几部电影中合作过，但随后在《荒野生存》（Into the Wild）中意义重大。他真的成为了在最后一局把球击出全垒打的主力。我们有过非常棒的合作经历。所以当我开始拍《国旗日》（Flag Day）时，我的习惯动作之一就是把剧本发给埃德，问他：“你觉得怎么样？”从早期阶段开始，我的感觉是，播放的歌曲的主要声音应该是女性，因为这是一个由女性驱动的故事。
Well, Ed and I had worked on a couple of films together in the past, but then significantly into the wild. He really became the hitter that put the ball over the fence in the last inning. And we had such a great experience. And so when I started Flag Day, one of my go-to things is I send Ed the script and say, what do you think? It had been from the early stages my sense that the leading voice of it, of the songs that would play would be female because it's a female-driven story.
但在父亲和女儿之间有一种平衡，我觉得我可以在有时插入男声，埃德把格伦·汉萨（Glenn Hansard）带了进来，他是个了不起的人，为《曾经》（Once）创作了歌曲。那家伙太棒了。是的，才华横溢的词曲作者。然后是我女儿，因为我听了太多伟大的女歌手和创作型歌手以及所有常见的人选。
But that there was a balance between the father and the daughter where I felt that I could insert male voices at times and Ed brought Glenn Hansard in who's a great, did the songs for once. Love that guy. Yeah. Brilliant songwriter. And then it was my daughter who I, because I was listening to so many great female singers and singer-songwriters and all of the usual suspects.
然后还有很多是通过其他人介绍给我的。但我找不到一个声音，听起来与我女儿的情感精神相和谐。然后我问了她，她推荐了猫力量（Cat Power）。埃德认识她，所以埃德不仅成了电影的词曲作者，还成了那部电影中歌曲库的策展人，与他们所有人合作，他们为此出了一张唱片，我非常期待听到它，因为这不仅是电影中的歌曲，我想还有受这个故事启发的歌曲。
And then a lot of people I was turned on to by others. But I couldn't find a voice that just seemed harmonious with my daughter's emotional spirit. And then I asked her and she suggested Cat Power. So Ed had known her and so Ed became kind of the, as well as a singer-songwriter on the movie, he became kind of the curator of the song bank on that thing and worked with all of them and they've got a record coming out of it, which I'm looking forward to hearing because it's not only the songs that are in the movie, but songs I suppose inspired by the story.
他负责配乐吗？他也是作曲家吗？不，作曲家是我长期合作的伙伴和朋友约瑟夫·维塔雷利（Joseph Vitarelli）。所以他负责器乐部分。但我们有时会借用彼此的主题，从歌曲中拿走一些器乐片段并将其分层叠加，这样它就像是我们拼凑起来的一床拼布被。好吧，我等不及要看它了。是的，真他妈的。
Did he score it as well? Is he also the composer? No, the composer is my longtime collaborator and friend, Joseph Vitarelli. So he did the instrumentals. But we at times borrowed from each other's themes and took some pieces of instrumental from the songs and layered it in so that it was kind of a quilt we put together. Well, I can't wait to see it. Yeah, no shit.
天哪，听起来太酷了。是的。我从来没能像那样用如此优美的语言来描述我做过的任何事情，听起来那么好，让人想去听或看。嘿，听着，肖恩，你最后一次打架是什么时候？说真的。老实说。最后一次是什么时候？
God, that sounds so cool. Yeah. I've never been able to describe anything that I've done like that in such an eloquent way that sounds so, makes people want to listen to it or watch it. Hey, listen, Sean, when was the last time you got into fist fight? Be real. Be honest. What was the last time?
是很久以前了。是的。是很久以前了。对我和来说是五年级。我知道你没问，但那是五年级。真的吗，杰森？是五年级吗？我挥拳却打空了。
It's been a long time. Yeah. It's been a long time. It's fifth grade for me. I know you're not asking, but it was fifth grade. Is it really, Jason? Is it fifth grade? And I swung and I missed.
是五年级吗？五年级。我在自己的心理里把五年级延长了很多年，而你挥拳打空了，这成了我职业生涯的隐喻。嘿，肖恩·潘，你知道的，首先，在我们放你走之前，我必须说，谢谢你的存在。你不需要在肖恩·海斯这里具体说明。你知道吗？
Is it fifth grade? Fifth grade. I extended fifth grade for many years in my own psyche and you swung and you missed as a metaphor for my career. Hey, Sean Penn, you know, first of all, before we let you go, I have to say, thank you for being. You don't need to specify on the Sean Hayes. You know?
是的。是的。你才是那个不需要说明的人。耶稣基督。我很抱歉，潘。请吧，肖恩。好的。海斯。
Yeah. Yeah. You're the one who doesn't need to. Jesus Christ. I'm so sorry, Penn. Go ahead, Sean. Okay. Hayes.
肖恩·潘，我必须说，我必须说，谢谢你成为LGBTQ社区如此不可思议的发言人和倡导者。你对哈维·米尔克（Harvey Milk）的塑造对我以及世界上的数百万人都不可思议。所以谢谢你，为这样一个不可思议的人做出了如此不可思议、不可思议的塑造。我很幸运能够做到这一点。是的。我曾为它试镜。
Sean Penn, I have to say, I have to say, thank you for being such an incredible voice and advocate for the LGBTQ community. Your portrayal of Harvey Milk was incredible to me and to millions of people around the world. So thank you for that, for such an incredible, incredible portrayal of an incredible man. I was very lucky to be able to do that. Yeah. I read for it.
我还在等待回音。然后另一件事是，当我还是个孩子的时候，我们的名字拼写一样，S-E-A-N。当我还是个孩子时，我所有的老师都会说，肖恩·海斯，就像他们搞不懂一样，直到《开放的学期》（Fast Times at Ridgemont High）上映。然后人们说，我说，你没听说过肖恩·潘吗？然后，所以谢谢你允许我在中西部地区，教人们如何拼写，如何念我的名字。所以我很感激。
I'm still waiting to hear. And then the other thing was when I was a kid, we spell our names the same, S-E-A-N. And all my teachers, when I was a kid, would be like, Sean Hayes, like they didn't understand it until fast times came out. And then people like, I go, you've never heard of Sean Penn. And then, so thank you for allowing me in the Midwest, teaching people how to spell, how to say my name. So I appreciate it.
我为你感到遗憾，那是肖恩·潘和那个角色，你知道的，作为一个与肖恩·康纳利（Sean Connery）和詹姆斯·邦德一起长大的人。是的，是的。还有另一件事。我当时想，你从来没听说过肖恩·康纳利或肖恩·潘吗？所以谢谢你。祝贺伊利诺伊州的所有教育工作者。谢谢你们不知道怎么念肖恩这个他妈的名字。
I feel for you that it was Sean Penn and that character, you know, as a guy who grew up with Sean Connery and James Bond. Yeah, yeah. And that's the other thing. I was like, you'd never heard of Sean Connery or Sean Penn. So thank you for that. Congratulations to all the educators from Illinois. Thank you for not knowing how to say the fucking name Sean.
我同意。我当时想，你们怎么会不知道那个？多么严厉的控诉。听着，肖恩·潘，伙计，非常感谢你加入我们。能请你来做客绝对是一件非常激动人心和荣幸的事，伙计。让我说，你们三个都是如此才华横溢的家伙。当我第一次听说你们在做一个播客时，我心里想，我得弄清楚怎么使用这个播客应用。
I agree. I was like, how do you guys not know that? What a blistering indictment. Listen, Sean Penn, man, thank you so much for joining us. What an absolute thrill and honor to have you on, man. Let me just say, you all three are such extraordinarily talented guys. And when I heard you were doing a podcast whenever I first heard about it, I thought to myself, I'm going to have to figure out how to use this podcast app.
但我至今还没弄懂。所以这基本上是我第一次听到它，它非常有趣，我期待着听到更多，并在屏幕上关注你们。超级、超级棒的团队。谢谢你，肖恩。我很感激。不要让它放慢你正在做的任何事情，请继续。继续做你正在做的一切。
And I still haven't. So this is essentially the first time I got to hear it and it's a lot of fun and I look forward to listening more and watching for you guys on the screen. Super, super great group. Thank you, Sean. I appreciate it. Don't let it slow down anything you're doing, please. Keep doing everything you're doing.
谢谢你所做的一切，并成为我们所有人的美好北极星。还有开拓者。谢谢。谢谢。真他妈的。保重，肖恩。谢谢。非常感谢你能来，老兄。
Thank you for all that stuff and being a nice north star for all of us. And trailblazer. Thank you. Thank you. Fucking hell. Take care, Sean. Thank you. Thank you very much for coming on, pal.
当然。再见。不客气。再见。再见。笔记本电脑一合。是的。笔记本电脑一合。
You bet. Bye. My pleasure. Bye. Bye. The laptop drop. Yeah. The laptop drop.
谁是第一个那样做的？嗯，听众得告诉我们，因为他们会记得。所以我们所描述的是，当我们说再见时，很多人还是会留在那里，然后我们离线，谢谢我。但现在很多人，人们开始实际上只是合上笔记本电脑。他是第三个在说声再见后就直接合上笔记本电脑的嘉宾。因为这最有意义。你知道为什么吗？
Who is the first one that did that? Well, the listener will have to tell us because they'll remember. So what we're describing is when we say goodbye, a lot of people just kind of hang out still and then we say offline, thank you for me. But a lot of people are now people just starting to actually just close their laptop. He's the third guest we've had who have just closed. They say bye to us and then they just close their laptop because that makes the most sense. Because you know what?
因为他是导演，而且他太棒了。因为他很聪明，他就像。这说明了很多问题。是的。这说明了很多问题。这就好像，那是关闭他妈的那东西最快的方法。如果我合上，我就不必去管什么“窗口关了吗”之类的话题了。你知道，我有一次在生活中遇到过肖恩·潘一次。
Because he's director and he's amazing. Because he's smart and he's like. It's very telling. Yeah. It's very telling. It's like, that's the quickest way to shut off the fucking thing. If I close, I don't have to go and like, is the window closed and blah, blah, blah. You know, one time I met Sean Penn one other time in my life.
我忘了对他说这个，他走到我面前，因为他刚好看完我做的一些。你可以直说，肖恩，我们知道你不是在说你自己。请吧。所以他，他说，他走过来，在我做的一个筹款活动的后台找到我。他说，你他妈疯了。然后我说，我他妈疯了。你才他妈疯了。
I forgot to say this to him and he came up to me because he just saw me do some. And you can just say, Sean, we know that you're not talking about yourself. Go ahead. So he, he said, he said to me, he comes up to me backstage at this fundraiser thing I did. He goes, you're fucking nuts. And I go, I'm fucking nuts. You're fucking nuts.
然后我们笑了，我们度过了一段美好的时光，因为他看到我做了这个疯狂的——这说来话长，但我为NBC做了一个宣传片，我在里面疯狂至极。但这是一个极好的赞美。我们对此付之一笑。而且他，但那是我唯一一次见到他。他是那样的善良、甜美和正常。没有在我们的播客上对他提起这件事，真是一个绝妙的决定。我知道。
And then we laughed and we had a good time and because he saw me do this crazy, it's too long of a story, but I did this promo thing for NBC and I was insane in it. And, but it was such a great compliment. We laughed about it. And he was, but that's the only other time I met him. He was so kind and sweet and normal. What a great decision not to share that with him when he's on our podcast. I know.
我知道。我只是把它留到他离开之后。干得好。天哪。我见过他。我见过他一次。我当时在外面。我当时在外面。
I know. I just save it till when he's gone. Way to go. God. I met him. I met him one time. I was out. I was out.
我知道。我只是留到他走后才用。真有你的。天哪。我见过他。我见过他一次。我当时在外面。我当时在外面。
This is a, this is going to be a crazy, a weird ass crew. You ready for the crew? Uh, I'm hanging at late night, one night at the Chateau Marmont years ago and it's me and Krasinski and Daniel Craig hold for applause, hold for applause. And then Sean was there with a friend and he was at a table and he just, it was like a late on a Sunday night. I remember it was after the Super Bowl, weirdly enough. And he said, Hey, you guys might, if we joined, we're like, no, come on.
这是一个，这将是一个疯狂的，奇怪的剧组。你们准备好迎接这个剧组了吗？呃，多年前的某天深夜，我在马蒙特城堡酒店闲逛，当时只有我和卡拉辛斯基以及丹尼尔·克雷格，请掌声鼓励，请掌声鼓励。然后肖恩和一位朋友也在那里，他在一张桌子旁，那是一个周日的深夜。我记得那是超级碗之后，说来也奇怪。他说，嘿，你们介意我们加入吗？我们说，不，来吧。
So he sat down and we had the greatest conversation. And of course, cause we just had our conversation. He's so cool and he's so articulate and he's got so many great ideas and thoughts and cool and, you know, his whole approach to every perspectives. And then at one point he was talking about and we were having this conversation and he said to me, you know, like, look, man, it's like what you do and like, you know, for you and for me as artists, the two of us as artists, blah, blah, blah, and I was like, and I'm just nodding along like, uh-huh, uh-huh.
于是他坐下来，我们进行了最棒的对话。当然，因为我们刚聊过。他太酷了，太健谈了，他有那么多伟大的想法、观点，而且很酷，你知道，他对各种视角的整体态度。然后有一次他在谈论，我们正在进行这场对话，他对我说，你知道的，听着，伙计，就像你做的那样，还有，你知道的，对你我来说作为艺术家，我们两个作为艺术家，等等等等，然后我就像，我只是点头附和，嗯哼，嗯哼。
And then we're leaving as we were driving home, Krasinski goes, we're in the car and it kind of quieted and goes, did fucking Sean Penn just refer to you and him as artists in the same? And I go, yes, dude. Okay. So yes. So don't the fucking fuck with me. All right.
然后我们要离开时，在开车回家的路上，卡拉辛斯基说，我们在车里，周围安静了下来，他说，操，肖恩·潘刚才是不是把你们俩都称为艺术家了？我说，是的，老兄。好吧，所以是的。所以别他妈的跟我开玩笑了。好吧。
He and I are. Again, another story that would have been good to bring up while he's off. I didn't want to. I'll do, I'll do my story that I should have brought up while he was with us. Let's call him back. He was shooting something on the sidewalk in, uh, in Manhattan. It was a night shoot. So it was, I don't know, it must have been like 3 30, 4 30 in the morning.
他和我是。又是一个故事，如果在他的节目上提出来会很好。我不想这么做。我来，我来分享我本该在他和我们在一起时提出来的故事。让我们回电话给他。他当时在曼哈顿的人行道上拍些东西。那是一场夜戏。所以当时，我不知道，大约应该是凌晨3点半、4点半吧。
It was a very, very, very, very, no cars since, since when did Hogan family shoot at night? Oh, well, um, so, uh, so we're on the sidewalk. It's like, I don't know, like West village or something like that. No cars coming down the, the street, um, and, uh, all the lights, all the cameras, everything is out on the sidewalk. So if you were driving by, you could see that we're shooting a movie. Obviously we're right there on the curb. And here comes one lonely little cab comes down, ripping down the, and it stops right
这是一个非常，非常，非常，非常，没有车，自从什么时候开始霍根家族在晚上拍戏了？哦，好吧，嗯，所以，嗯，所以我们在人行道上。大概是，我不知道，比如西村之类的地方。街上没有车过来，嗯，然后，所有的灯光，所有的摄像机，所有的东西都在人行道上。所以如果你开车经过，你能看到我们在拍电影。显然我们就在路边。然后来了一辆孤独的小出租车，飞速开过来，然后停在
in front of the set. So he's like six feet from us and the back door opens and outwalks Sean Penn. And he just gets up and we think, oh, he must live around here. He just gets up, stands out of the cab, looks at the whole shooting crew is about 150 of us. And he just holds his arms out and he goes, New York city. Huh? Am I right?
片场正前方。所以他离我们大约六英尺，后门打开了，肖恩·潘走了出来。他只是站起来，我们想，哦，他一定住在附近。他刚从出租车里站出来，看着整个拍摄剧组，大约有150人，他只是伸开双臂说，纽约市，哈？我说的对吗？
Gets back in the cab. Hits it. No. Keep going. Wow. I'm like, you guys are shooting a movie. I'm a movie star. It's four in the morning.
又钻进出租车。开走了。不。继续。哇。我想，你们在拍电影。我是个电影明星。现在才凌晨四点。
How about it? Huh? Is this great or what? It keeps going. We all just thought it was the greatest thing ever. Wait a second of all the three stories that should have been told to him, that was the best one by a fucking mile, which makes you so much dumber again. Yeah.
怎么样？哈？这不是很棒吗？他继续往前开。我们都认为这是有史以来最棒的事。等等，在所有应该告诉他的三个故事中，那是绝对最棒的一个，这让你再次显得笨得多。是的。
Bye country mile. Bye. He just, oh, I had such a good one. Okay. Go ahead. Hey, Jason, are you just saying he don't waste it? By the way, don't waste it. No, this is perfect.
差得远呢。差得远。他只是，哦，我有一个这么棒的故事。好吧。说吧。嘿，杰森，你是在说他别浪费了吗？顺便说一句，别浪费。不，这太完美了。
Wait. So Jason, are you just saying that he drove up as a fly by, yeah, he would go right by the set. That's the first three. It's the first time we've had three buys. It's a triple bypass. Smart. Nice.
等等。所以杰森，你只是说他路过时顺便停了一下，是的，他直接从片场旁边经过。这是我们第一次有三个“顺便（buys）”。这是一个三联过桥（triple bypass）。聪明。不错。
Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Amjarf. The next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music or by subscribing to Wondry Plus in the Wondry app.
聪明。不错。Smart由贝内特·巴尔巴科（Bennett Barbaco）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·安杰尔夫（Rob Amjarf）100%有机且手工制作。下一集将在周内发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过Wondry应用程序订阅Wondry Plus。
Smart. That's it for this episode of Wondry Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smart。本期Wondry Plus节目就到这里。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。